يا لط
هكذا اذا بدل المشهد اليوم مباني تتداعى
وتنهر واحده تلو الاخرى في مشهد مرعب
ومؤلم لم تكن ليله هانئه على مناطق جنوبي
تركيا وشمال سوريا وكلمه كارثه باتت قليله
على محل بالسكان هناك نداءات الاستغاثه
تعالى والصراخ دوا في سماء تركيا وسوريا
منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى قتلى وضحايا
بالالاف عدا عن المفقودين زلزال مدمر بقوه
بلغت 7.8 درجات ومركزه على عمق 17.9
كيلومترات لم يحدث مثله منذ قرن هزه طرفي
الحدود التركيه السوريه وشعرت به الدول
المجاوره السلطات في انقره استنفرت كافه
مؤسستها الخدميه والطارئه والدفاعيه
واقامت ممرا جويا لتمكين فرق البحث
والانقاذ من الوصول الى المناطق المتضرره
فيما تخيم مناطق شمال غربي سوريا حاله من
العجز والالم والفقد لالاف العائلات في
وقت سابق عمال واغاثه ومسعفون الزمن
لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاضه اما بالنسبه للعدد
الاجمالي او حصيله عدد القتلى والجرحى فان
اخر حصيله لاعداد الضحايا بلغت الفا
وسبعمائه
واكثر من 11 الف اصابه في تركيا بحسب
اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه فيما سجل
تدمير اكثر من
5600 مبنى وتشهد المستشفيات في تركيا
ضغوطا بسبب كثره اعداد المصابين هذا في
تركيا اما في سوريا مشاهدينا فقد ارتفعت
الحصيله الى الف
وثلاثمائه وثمانيه واربعين قتيلا ولا
احصاءات دقيقه حتى اللحظه لعدد الاصابات
بحسب اذا المصادر فيما دمر الزلزال مئات
المنازل ليفاقم من بؤس السوريين في شمال
البلاد
اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور التي تتوالى اذا
منذ الصباح لهذا الزلزال المدمر الذي دمر
اذن
العديد من المباني والمنازل خاصه في
المنطقه الحدوديه ما بين تركيا وسوريا
هناك حاله حداد اذا في تركيا اعلنها
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان فيما تستمر اذا
جهود الاغاثه لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه
والعثور على نجيم من تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
احنا
بس الله هيك احنا نايمين
هذا هون
[موسيقى]
وتابع معكم تغطيه وقائع هذا الزلزال
المدمر نذهب الان الى هذه الصور المباشره
هي من ديار بكر في تركيا حيث تتواصلوا
جهود الانقاذ كما نتابع ايضا لانتشال
الضحايا او الناجين من تحت الانقاض اذا
كما تتابعنا في هذه الصور طبعا في جو بارد
شديد البروده تتواصل جهود الانقاذ وهذه
الفرق منذ ساعات بعد ان استحاله
المباني الى ركام طبعا وسط حاله من الهلع
والحزن طبعا احد النجين وصف لحظه الزلزال
بانه كان لحظه تشبه نهايه العالم طبعا
هيئه المسح الجيولوجي الامريكي قالت ان
الزلزال الاول الذي ضرب في الفجر كانت
بلغت قوته 7.8 درجات على مقياس
وبعده بساعات زلزال اخر بقوه 7.5 درجه على
مقياس لخضر ايضا على بعد اكثر من 100 كم
طبعا شاهدوا مشاهدينا كما تتابعون اذا
فرق الانقاذ تحاول
جاهده البحث عن ناجين
واخراج كذلك الضحايا طبعا على ذكر الضحايا
الحصيله في ارتفاع مستمر اخر حصيله وصلتنا
اذا كما تتابعون على الشاشه 1762 قتيلا في
تركيا حتى الان بينما في سوريا
1348 قتيلا حتى الان فيما لا تزال هناك
مناطق اصلا لم تصل اليها فرق الانقاذ في
سوريا خاصه في المناطق الخاضعه للسيطره
المعارضه السوريه هناك فرق الخوذ البيضاء
فقط هي التي تقوم بجهود هناك لانقاذ طبعا
النجين كذلك واخراج الضحايا من تحت الركام
بالنظر طبعا الى الظروف الجويه القاسيه
التي تمر بها المنطقه في هذه الفتره وكذلك
انقطاع الكهرباء كذلك يعقد الجهود
انتشال الجثث واخراج الناجين ربما كذلك
اذا هذه هي الصور تستمر مشاهد محاولات
انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه الصور الان معنا من
ديار بكر من تركيا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يلا
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
وجع قلبي
[موسيقى]
افدت وكاله الانباء السعوديه بان ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان قدم
التعازي هاتفيا لرئيس تركيا في ضحايا
زلزال واكد الامير محمد بن سلمان وقوف
السعوديه ومساندتها لتركيا لتجاوز هذه
الكارثه الطبيعيه بدوره اعرب اردوغان عن
تقديره لموقف السعوديه ووقوفها الى جانب
تركيا في هذا الظرف الصعب
اعلنت سلطات الرومانيه ارسال وحدات انقاذ
الى تركيا للمساعده في عمليات الاغاثه
جراء تداعيه الزلزال وتتضمن الفرق تلك
عشرات من المختصين بالانقاذ وعددا من
الكلاب المدربه على البحث تحت الانقاطع
اكد بيان للجيش الاسرائيلي ان بعثه مشتركه
للدفاع والخارجيه توجهت الى المنطقه التي
وقع فيها الزلزال المدمر في تركيا لتقديم
المساعده وتحمل البعثه اسم اغصان الزيتون
البعثه التي تتراسها قياده الجبهه
الداخليه ستغادر اليوم على متن طائره
تابعه لسلاح الجو من قاعده
وستباشر بمجرد وصولها مهمه الانقاذ
هذا وقال رئيس برنامج الغذاء العالمي
ان فرق الطوارئ التابعه للبرنامج تستعد
لتقديم المساعده اذا اقتضت الضروره بعد
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا وقدم بيزلي
عبر حسابه على تويتر تعازيه لعائلتي ضحايا
الزلزال
نتابع مباشره من اسطنبول مع مراسل العربيه
زيدان زين كلو زيدان اهلا بك معنا قبل
قليل كنا نتابع صورا من ديار بكر هل هناك
اي تحديث لحصيله الضحايا للزلزال والى اين
وصلت جهود ليغاثه حتى الان
[موسيقى]
التي ضربها زلزلان قويان مدمرا الاول كانت
جدته سبعه فاصله سبعه والثاني بعد تسع
ساعات فقط كانت شدته او قوه الزلزال
7.6 بالتالي حجم الدمار في كهرمان مرعش
كبير جدا والصور التي شاهدناها قبل قليل
وبثتها وسائل عن تركيا حي كامل سوريا في
الارض فقط مبنى ضخم ايضا هذا المبنى الضخم
ايل للسقوط مبنى ايلا مبنى للسقوط او على
وجه السقوط وحول هذا المبنى اكثر يعني
عشرات البيوت المدمره بشكل كامل هذا
المشهد حقيقه صهيب يلخص
الحكايه اليوم في تركيا فرق الانقاذ في
هذا الحي في كهرمان مرعش تحاول جاهده
الوصول ويعني اين اينما
ذهبت اضافه الى كهرمان مركز الزلزال الاول
ما هي المناطق الاخرى الاكثر تضررا خاصه
في جنوب تركيا زيدان
نعم كل الولايات القريبه من كهرمان مرعش
تبررت بشكل كبير على وجه الخصوص ولايه
غازي عنتاب جنوب كهرمان لان هذه الولايه
اضافه الى
التاثرها بالزلازل القويه او الزلزلان
القويان شهدت اقوى
هزات ارتداديه كانت اقوى
بلغت شدتها 6.6 نتحدث عن اكثر من 220 هزا
اعتداديه شهدتها ولايات غازي عنتاب اضنه
عثمان
هل ما تزال هل شعرت ببعض الهزات
الارتداديه هل ما تزال مستمره حتى الان
[موسيقى]
استعدادها وفعلا بعض الدول ارسلت
هل هناك فرق اجنبيه بدات بالوصول الى
تركيا وتقدم المساعده في جهود الاغاثه
والبحث عن ناجين زياد زيدان
نعم اول فريق انقاذ وصل من اذربيجان حوالي
370 شخصا كانت اول دوله اعلنت انها سترسل
فرق انقاذ هذا الفريق وصل الى تركيا مساء
هذا اليوم وتوجه فورا الى المناطق
المنكوبه لا نعلم بالضبط الى اي ولايه على
وجه التحديد اتجه هذا الفريق لكن ما
علمناه ان 17 طائره كانت تحط تباعا في
مطاري اضنه وغازي عنتاب كل هذه الطائرات
كانت محمله بالمساعدات الطبيه وبفرق
الانقاذ طبعا عدا المساعدات الخارجيه
والاقم التي اتت من الخارج هناك اطقم
كبيره او عادات كبيره من التواصل من
الطواقم الطبيه وفرق الانقاذ وصلت الى
المناطق المنكوبه من عديد الولايات كانت
الرئيس التركي كان يتحدث عن 9,000
منقذ
ومتطوع ضمن الطواقم الطبيه وهم من
المدنيين اضافه اكثر من 3500 من العراق
الجيش التركي اضافه الى الجسر الجوي طبعا
صهيب الذي قرر الجيش التركي فتح جسر جوي
او اطلق جسر جوي
للمناطق المنكوبه طبعا ايضا وزاره الدفاع
التركيه ارسلت سفينه ضخمه لتقل
السكان من ولايه هاتاي مع الاسف لن يستفيد
من هذه السفينه سوى سكان ولايه هاتاي او
ربما المناطق القريبه منها لان الطرق التي
تصل مثلا ولايه عنتاب بولايه هاتاي
انهارك ودمرت باجزاء اجزاء منها وهذا
بطبيعه الحال عطفه لحركه السير او حركه
انتقال المواطنين من ولايه الى اخرى وايضا
ادخل وصول فرق الانقاذ من ولايه الى اخرى
عن طريق البر اضف الى ذلك صهيب باوجه لها
ان الحاله الجويه او الطقس البارد يزيد من
صعوبه المهمه سواء على
كوادر كوادر فرق الانقاذ او حتى على
السكان الذين هاموا على وجوههم في الشوارع
هذا هو السؤال التالي لك هؤلاء من هاموا
على وجوههم يا زيدان او من كتب لهم عمر
جديد بعد هذا الزلزال كيف سيبيتون ليلتهم
الاولى بعد هذا الزلزال كيف واين سيبيتون
اقصد كيف يتم التكفل بهم هذه الليله
نعم بطبيعه الحال
المراكز الهواء هي عباره عن المدارس
والجامعات والسكن الجامعي وايضا الصلاه
الرياضيه وكل مراكز الاوقاف وحتى المساجد
لكن حتى في هذه المراكز هناك رعب وهلا
شديد من الهزات الارتداديه لذلك الكثير
يفضل ان يبيت ليلته في العراء وفي الحدائق
وفي اماكن خاليه انا اقربائي مثلا في
ولايه غازي عنتاب تحدثت اليهم قبل قليل
يعني يبيتون في العراء ولا يريدون
نعم مع الاسف من ان نتحدث اليوم غازي
عنتاب تتعرض لمنخفض جوي وثلوج منذ عده
ايام
والثلوج تستمر بالهطول ان كان في غازي
عنتاب او في ملاطيا او في كهرمان مرعش كل
هذه الجو البارد الحراره تقريبا خمس درجات
تحت الصفر في بعض المناطق وفي كهرمان مرعش
اكثر بطبيعه الحال بارده اكثر من بقيه
المناطق درجه الحراره اكثر من اقل من ذلك
مع الاسف الظروف الجويه لا تساعد كثيرا ان
كان فرق الانقاذ او حتى المواطنين الذين
يرغبون في القضاء او القضاء لا يفهم في
اماكن مفتوحه بعيدا عن اماكن الايواء ومع
تحذيرات شديده من كل السلطات التركيه وكل
اجهزه الدوله تحذر المواطنين من العوده
الى المنازل بسبب الهزات الارتداديه لا لا
قسم كبير من المباني
فيه بعض التصدعات او بعض
طيب زيدان اسمح لي اسالك عن نقطه اخرى
هامه انه بسبب الزلزال كان هناك حديث على
تاثر انبوب الغاز الذي يعني يزود عديد
المناطق التركيه بالغاز
هل ما مدى تاثر خدمه الخدمات كذلك في باقي
الاراضي التركيه
بسبب هذا الزلزال الان
نعم اولا هناك عده خدمات غير موجوده في
بعض الولايات بدايه من شبكه الاتصالات
تحديدا في ولايتها وكرمال مرعش هناك مشكله
حقيقيه في شبكه الاتصالات نتيجه تحطم
ابراج البث ايضا هناك موضوع ازمه
المحروقات في بعض المناطق لاسيما المناطق
البعيده والنائيه ايضا هناك ازمه انابيب
الغاز تحديدا انا تحدثت عنها نائب الرئيس
التركي انبوب الغاز بين ولايتين
وغازي عنتاب هذا الانبوب تضرر ويحتاج عده
ايام للصيانه ايضا انبوب الغاز الذي يصل
بين كهرمان مرعش وغازي عنتاب ايضا يحتاج
الى عده ايام من الصيانه انبوب الغاز
الواصل الى ولايه كلس وهي ايضا لم نذكر
هذه الولايه ايضا كان فيها اضرار
تاثر بشكل طفيف لكن من يؤثر على ضغط الغاز
لذلك سيستم دخل هذا في هذا الانبوب
بالعموم هناك مشاكل يعني ليست مشاكل عامه
في كل المناطق في بعض المناطق توجد مشاكل
وبعض المناطق لا توجد مشاكل بنفس النوع
ومشاكل الاتصالات والكهرباء او حتى موضوع
توفير الماء في مثلا في ولايه ملاسيا كل
هذه المشاكل تحاول السلطات التركيه
التعاطي مع قدر الامكان في محاوله تخسيس
هذه الازمه على المواطنين وعلى المنكوبين
في تلك الولايات شكرا جزيلا لك زيدان
زنكلو سنتابع معك على مدار الساعات
المقبله ايضا اخر التطورات كذلك
وما ستصل اليه جهود الانقاذ اذا المستمره
كما نتابع معكم مشاهدينا في هذه الصور في
المناطق في خاصه في جنوبي تركيا اذا
مشاهدينا نذكر فقط باخر الاخبار العاجله
المبعوثه الاموي الى سوريا يقول ان
السوريين بحاجه ماسه الى المساعده الدوليه
جراء الزلزال كذلك قبل قليل كان هناك دعوه
للمجتمع الدولي لمساعده الالاف من
المتضررين الزلزال في سوريا خاصه المناطق
التي يعني هي تحت سيطره المعارضه السوريه
يعني تعاني من نقص في وصول فرق الانقاذ
ووجودها اصلا
لانقاذ الناجين او لاخراج الضحايا بلجيكا
تعلن ارسال فريق طبي ومعدات طبيه الى
تركيا بعد هذا الزلزال
بالحديث عن الضحايا نعود ونذكر انه 1772
حتى الان حصله القتلى جراء الزلزال في
تركيا و 1348 في سوريا في المقابل هناك
انقاذ
645 شخصا من تحت الانقاض بعد هذا الزلزال
في تركيا اذا هذه اخر التطورات مستمرون في
التغطيه تتعرض تركيا مشاهدينا باستمرار
لزلازل وهزات ارضيه حصدت الاف الارواح
ودبرت المباني والبنى التحتيه نتابع
منذ عام 1500 شيدت تركيا نحو 23 زلزالا
مدمرا تجاوزت قوتها سبع درجات وفق تقديرات
علماء الجيولوجيا والمؤرخين زلزال ارزنجان
1939 بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله تسعه تسبب
بمصرع 33 الف شخص واصابه نحو 100 الف
زلزال لاتيك
1943 بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله سته دمر
75% من ابنيه المنطقه واودى بحياه 20300
شخص
زلزال تشالديران بلغت قوته سبع درجات
فاصله خمسه تسبب بمسرعي ثلاثه الاف
وثمانمائه واربعين شخصا
زلزال غولتشوك بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله
اثنين تسبب بمصرع
894 شخصا
زلزالو فان 2011 بلغت قوته سبع درجات
فاصله اثنين ادى الى وفاه اكثر من 70 شخصا
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر حركه
حاره كامله
بدنا نحكم العالم كلها جايه ربعه او عم
تعاونها تفرجهم يا يا ريف الجنوب يتفرجهم
العالم كلها جايه ربحوا ما تعاونها دعكم
دعكم احنا مالنا حدا ما لنا غير رب
العالمين ضل كل واحد قاعد ببيت ولا احد
يجي
اتفرجوا اتفرجوا يساعدنا
وفعلا مشاهدينا تشير للمعطياتها لانه
الوضع في سوريا اصعب بكثير من تركيا وهناك
مناطق اصلا لم تصل اليها فرق اغاثه لاخراج
ان كان الضحايا او ناجين العراق الان يدخل
على الخطوه يعلن فتحه جسر جوي الى تركيا
وسوريا لاغاثه ضحايا الزلزال مع الانا في
هذه التغطيه من باريس دكتور بدوي رهبان
المستشار لدى اليونسكو المتحده لشؤون
المناخ
ومستشار الكوارث الطبيعيه مرحبا بكم معنا
بدايه دكتور بدوي بدايه جهود الانقاذ في
هكذا كوارث ما الذي يجب توفيره
من اجل انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه
يجب توفير كل الماديات وكل المادات
والمواد لذلك الان الساعه هي للانقاذ
والاغاثه طبعا وايضا يجب ان نفترض ان
الاهالي المنكوبين يجب ان يعرفوا اين
يستطيعوا ومتى يستطيعوا العوده الى
منازلهم اذا بالتوازي يجب متابعه عمليات
الانقاذ والاغاثه في الساعات المقبله
والايام المقبله وبموازاه ذلك ان نوفر
مياه للمنكوبين ان نوفر المواد
المواد للاكل ان نوفر المواد الطبيه وايضا
ان يكون هناك من قبل المهندسين وفرق
الهندسه مسح وكشف على الابنيه الابنيه
خاصه المتصاعده لكي يستطيع السكان اذا
كانت ابنيتهم لم تتصدع ان يستطيعوا العوده
الى منازلهم لان بقائهم في الاماكن
الشاسعه
سوف يعكد عمليات الانكاز وثالثا يجب ان
يكون هناك تعبئه على المستوى الدولي تحت
مظله الامم المتحده تعبئه سريعه وان يكون
هناك تنسيق بين كل الدول التي تقدم اغاثه
الان ان لا يكون هناك
عمليات عشوائيه كل ذلك يتطلب تنسيق وادراك
وتنظيم هذا هو الوقت الان لهذه الاولويات
وطبعا في المرحله الثانيه تكون الاولويات
لكي نعالج كيف يكون العياده الاعمار
واعاده الحياه الى طبيعتها بالسرعه لان
هذا
الحصيله ترتفع تقفز كنا نتحدث عن
1772 قتيل في زلزال تركيا الان الحصيله
ترتفع الى 2316 قتيلا في زلزال تركيا حسب
اداره الكوارث التركيه اخر تحديث اذا
المشاهدين لضحايا هذا الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب تركيا اذا 316 قتيلا الان في تحديث
لحصيله الضحايا بينما تستمر جهود الانقاذ
واخراج كذلك الضحايا من تحت الركام طيب
دكتور بدوي في للاسف للاسف للاسف ان هذه
الحصيله سوف ترتفع يجب ان نتوقع ان حصيله
هذه الكارثه سوف ترتفع للاسف لان هناك
عوامل عده تجتمع لتجعل من هذه الكارثه
اكبر مما نتوقعه هذه الكارثه اصطدمت بعده
عوامل عوامل طبيعيه عوامل جيولوجيه عوامل
تكتونيه ولكن ايضا عوامل مناخيه ان
العاصفه التي تضرب المنطقه الان سوف تؤخر
عمليات الانقاذ
انزلاقات الارضيه سوف تهدد بعض الامور
وكذلك يجب ان يكون هناك وعي بان
الارتداد
نحن ندخل في نوبه
سوف تعكد عمليات الانقاذ الارتدادات من
الزلزال وايضا البعض العوامل سوف تعكد كل
ذلك كل ذلك يتطلب صبرا ويتطلب وعي وخاصه
يعني فيما يتعلق
بالناجين يعني يعني سيكون هناك صعوبه في
ظل هذا الطقس البارد شديد البروده كيف
يمكن التكفل بهم حديث على انه اناس يبيتون
في العراء خاصه في المناطق السوريه في
شمال سوريا على على الحدود يعني هم اصلا
يعانون اصلا من ظروف صعبه ومن تبعات الحرب
والتوتر الحاصل هناك في المنطقه الحدوديه
الان مع الزلزال وهذا المنخفض الجوي في
مناطق اخرى هناك لجوء الى المساجد مثلا او
الى المدارس
لكن في المقابل دكتور الى اين يمكن ان
يلجا هؤلاء
يجب ان يكون ان لم يستطيعوا اللجوء الى
بعض الابنيه لانها متصاعده يجب ان يكون
تنظيم لمخيمات مخيمات مؤقته وان لا تكون
هذه المخيمات المؤقته بعد اشهر واعوام ان
تكون دائمه هذا كله يتطلب تنظيم طبعا الان
هو الوقت للانقاذ والاغاثه ولكن يجب على
السلطات ان تعي ان هذا الامر يتعدى قدرتها
وان على الدول كلها ان تستجيب لا نكتفي
فقط ب 45 دوله ولكن بمجموعه الامم المتحده
وبالمجتمعات الانسانيه ان يكون هناك تعبئه
عامه وفي الساعات والايام القادمه لا يجب
ان ننتظر يجب ان نتخطى كل العوامل وكل
النزاعات وكل
الامور الجيو السياسيه والسياسيه ويجب ان
نركز ايضا ان الزلزال يضرب بلدين يضرب
تركيا ويضرب سوريا هذان البلدان هما بحاجه
ماسه الان الى الاغاثه والى الانق الى
المساعدات نعم وتحديث اخر الان مشاهدينا
اداره الكوارث التركيه تتحدث عن تدمير
6,27 مبنى جراء هذا الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب تركيا وسوريا اذا
فجره هذا اليوم
الحصيله اذا حتى الان
نتحدث اذا عن مقتل اكثر من 2000 الفي شخص
في تركيا وفي حصيله يعني اوليه كذلك مقابل
للارتفاع كما ذكر ضيفي 1348 قتيلا في
سوريا وحدها حتى الان بينما في تركيا هناك
الفين وثلاثمائه وسته عشر قتيلا واكثر من
15 الف اصابه اذا في تركيا الان حديث عن
تدمير سته الاف مئتين وسبعه عشر مبنى جراء
الزل
طيب دكتور بدوي رهبان فيما يتعلق بتسيير
هذه الكارثه ذكرتها انه خاصه بالنسبه
لسوريا يجب تنحيه الخلافات السياسيه الان
هل يعني من خلال ما تبعتموه من معطيات حتى
الان ترون انه هناك جهود ايضا
يمكن النظر اليها على انها نحت الجانب
السياسي او الخلافات السياسيه وذهبت
لانقاذ الناس في مناطق شمال سوريا
نحن نلاحظ اليوم ان هناك اهتمام دولي
اهتمام عالمي على كل الصعد في بهذه
الماساه بهذه الكارثه لذلك ان ان الان
امام هناك فرصه لكي نبين ان المظاهر
الطبيعيه ان الظواهر الطبيعيه ان الطبيعه
لا تعرف
بالحدود الجغرافيه لا الزلازل لا تعترف
بالحدود الجغرافيه ولا تعترف بنزاعات
المسلحه ان الزلازل ليست هي التي تقتل ما
يقتل هو الابنيه التي تنهار هو البنى
التحتيه التي ليست سليمه هو العدم الاغاثه
في الوقت المحدد هو عدم التعاون هذا ما
يقتل لذلك يجب ان نواجه هذه الكارثه بحكمه
وبوعي
وبتعاون دولي وتعاون اقليمي على كل
المستويات وان نتجاوز ما يكون هناك من
خلافات جانبيه مهما كانت هامه وضروريه
شكرا جزيلا لك على انضمامك الينا في هذه
التغطيه دكتور بدوي رهبان انت مستشار لدى
اليونسكو الامم المتحده لشؤون المناخ
ومستشار الكوارث الطبيعيه
اذا المشاهدين المستمرون معكم في التغطيه
اظهرت صور من داخل احدى مستشفيات سوريا
تحديدا في مدينه الاتارب التابعه لمحافظه
حلب حيث يتلقى العلاج المصابون جراء
الزلزال المدمر
[موسيقى]
اوضح وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلانك واشنطن تقيم وخيارات الاستجابه
الشامله للزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا واكد بلانكا في بيانه ان بلاده
ستبدو كل ما في وسعها لمساعده المتضررين
خلال الفتره المقبله مضيفا على اتصال وثيق
مع انقره وشركائها في المجال الانساني
لتحديد ما تحتاجه المنطقه في الايام
القادمه بل يمكن اشار الى ان جهود
لاستجابه الاوليه في تركيا جاريه بالفعل
مؤكدا ان المنظمات الانسانيه المدعومه من
واشنطن في سوريا تستجيب لاثار الزلزال في
جميع انحاء البلاد
ومصر الان تعلن ارسال مساعده اذا في عاجله
الى تركيا لمواجهه تداعيات الزلزال معنا
الان من اسطنبول الكاتب الصحفي فراس رضوان
اوغلو استاذ فراس اهلا بك معنا يعني حصيله
الضحايا مستمره في الارتفاع كذلك وجهود
الانقاذ
مستمره كذلك بدايه كيف تقيم الجهود جهود
السلطات التركيه والتعاون الدولي كذلك حتى
الان بعد هذا الزلزال المدمر
نعم يعني بالنسبه للجهود اداء اظن ان يعني
فوق الطاقه او فوق قدره الاستيعاب التي
تمتلكها ربما افاد او الطوارئ او حتى
الهلال الاحمر هم يقومون حقيقه بعمل جبار
جدا لكن اظن ان الكارثه اكبر منهم واكبر
من قدرتهم الاستيعابيه على مسافه الف اكثر
من 1500 كيلو مترا من يعني افقيا بين
المدن اضافه الى انها عشر ولايات ما
تتضمنه من مدن وقرى حتى الان الحقيقه يعني
الارقام تزداد بشكل مضطرد وبشكل سريع
بالنسبه للقتله والجراحه كما تفضلتم قبل
قليل بان يعني الاعداد القصبح 2316
[موسيقى]
البنى المدمره اكثر من 6200 بناء ويعني
المصابون تتجاوز
1300 يعني حتى قبل قليل كان هناك نداء
السلطات الطبيه تخشب تخشاه من ما يسمى من
هيبوتيرم او
خفض انخفاض حراره الجسم بسبب الجو البارد
وهذا ربما سيؤثر على الجميع سواء
المحاصرون تحت الانقاذ او الذين ربما
يقومون في في اعمال وفيه بتراء ولذلك يعني
هذه احدى المناشدات ربما سيتم ايجاد صيغه
ما ليس فقط الغذاء والشراب بعض الادويه
التي تفيد في في هذا الاصلاح حتى
علمني اسالك قليلا على انه يعني هذا
الزلزال ضرب منطقه مضطربه منذ سنوات نتحدث
عن المنطقه الحدوديه ما بين تركيا وسوريا
دعني اسالك عن الجانب السوري يبدو انه
الجهود يعني على قدم وساق في تركيا ماذا
عن سوريا ماذا عن المناطق الخاضعه
للمعارضه السوريه كنت استمعت لشهاده احد
الناجين في شمال سوريا انه هناك مبنى مدمر
مباني مدمره ولا احد وصل اصلا هناك لتقديم
جهود من اجل اخراج ان كان قتلى او ناجين
نعم يعني قد يكون وارد الحقيقه لان لم
تصلح السلطات التركيه عن ارسال اي وفود
الى هناك هذا اولا ثانيا يعني الصدمه
الكبيره في تركيا نفسها ربما لم يستوعبها
حتى الان الكل يعني ليس فقط
المجتمع التركي بل حتى المسؤولين
المتطوعون الافاد غيرها لكن اظن هذا الامر
ربما مع مع الساعات سيتدارك مع وصول كثير
من فرق الانقاذ التي يتم ارسالها تباعا
يعني ابتداء من اذربيجان والعراق قبل قليل
ربما بلجيكا اعلنت اصول الفرق او ارسال
الفرق لانقاذ تركيا تحتاج الى بدايه الفعل
الى فرق انقاذ
والاسعافات الامور الطبيه بما تتضمنه
بجميع الامور يعني المستشفيات المتنقله
الادويه الاحتياجيه التي يحتاجها في كل
الاصعده
ربما الشوادر الخيم التي تحتاج لي على
الاقل نصب بعض المساعد الطبيه التي
يحتاجونها في كل مكان حتى
قدرات الجيش التركي التي هي معروفه ان كل
دوله لديها للجيش لديه مخزون الخاص من
الامور طبيه وغيرها تم استخدامه الان من
الاستفاده منه في انقاذ الناس او اجزائيه
حتى البارجه او البارزه الكبيره التيسي
وضع وطن الان كمستشفى بحري ممكن ان نقول
رغما سفينه عسكريه ضخمه جدا لكن ستقوم
بايواء ونقل الناس فقط في المناطق
الساحليه طبعا في عطايا واسكندرون التي
ايضا تضررت وحصل الحريق الذي
عرضتموها على شاشتكم الكريمه قبل فترات
بسبب الزلزال الذي ضرب لواء اسكندرون هناك
الحقيقه ننتظر التصريحات
الوارده من قبل المسؤولين الاتراك حتى
افات بسبب ان الارقام كل لحظه يصبح عليها
تغيير بشكل كبير شكرا جزيلا لك على
مداخلتك معنا رضوان فراس رضوان انت كاتب
الصحفي كنت معنا من اسطنبول
الى المشاهدين المستمرون معكم في هذه
التغطيه الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا اخر حصيله
2316 قتيلا في تركيا
وحصيله اوليه كذلك 1348 قتيلا في سوريا
حتى الان اكدت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
ان فرنسا سترسل سبعه عشر عنصرا من فرق
الانقاذ وخمسه من فرق الاطفاء الى تركيا
بالاضافه الى افراد من مركز الازمات
والدعم وذلك استجابه لطلب الدعم الدولي
الذي قدمته تركيا
لكن مشاهدينا ثمه نصائح نشرت الفرق
المختصه للفت النظر الى سبل التصرف
والوقايه من كافه مراحل حدوث الزلزال
انطلاقا من الوقايه التي يجب اتباعها في
الحالات الطبيعيه مرورا بكيفيه الوقايه
اثناء حدوث الهزات وبعد حدوثها المزيد من
التفاصيل في العرض التالي
[موسيقى]
معنى الان من القاهره الدكتور عباس شراقي
استاذ الجيولوجيا في جامعه القاهره دكتور
اهلا بكم معنا هيئه المسح الجيولوجي
الامريكيه قالت ان الزلزال الاول كان 7.8
درجه على مقياس نختر وبعد ساعات الزلزال
الثاني كان 7.5 تقريبا نفس الشده هل هذا
طبيعي
مساء الخير على حضرتك والساده المشاهدين
الحقيقه يعني المنطقه
بتشهد لاول مره
زلازل بهذا الشكل يمكن كان في زلزال سنه
39 بنفس القوه 7.8 لكن ما يحدث اليوم غير
مسبوق لان هناك طبيعي يقرب من 230 زلزال
بالضبط 230 زلزال وليس زلزال واحد وفيهم
اربع زلازل كبرى اللي زي ما حضرتك ذكرت
اتنين منهم وفي اتنين سته ونص وسته واتنين
من عشره واي واحد منهم كان كفيل ان هو
يدمر
هذه المناطق اللي حصل فيها
وبالاضافه الى اكثر من 220 زلزال بشده
تتراوح يعني حول
والزلازل في يعني في هذا اليوم حصلت في
اماكن مختلفه يمكن اشدها حصلت في المنطقه
الحدوديه ما بين تركيا وسوريا ولكن
الزلازل حصلت في منتصف تركيا
وحصلت في شرق وغرب تركيا حتى وصلت الى
جزيره قبرص فهذا هو الغير في القاهره هناك
نصف القاهره شعروا ببعض من هذه الزلازل
ومن هذه الهزات
لا ما هنا هذه هي نفس الزلازل لكن موجات
الزلزاليه للزلازل بتنتشر في طبقات
الصخريه زي القرى اللي بترمى في بتحصل
موجات دائريه لو سمحت اعذرنا على المقاطعه
ولكن كلامك مهم جدا تقول اذا تؤكد انه هذا
الكم من الزلازل غير طبيعي يعني وبهذه
الشده يعني انه زلزلان على الاقل فوق سبعه
فاصل خمسه او سبعه فاصل خمسه وهناك المئات
من الزلازل الاخرى يعني طوال هذه الساعات
الماضيه طيب ما هو التفسير لماذا
التفسير هذه المنطقه
يعني احنا
الكره الارضيه مغطاه
صلبه تسمى القشره الارضيه
سمك القشره الارضيه يختلف من المكان الى
اخر يعني من حوالي سته كيلو الى سبعين
كيلو متر بيزيد عند المرات الجبليه هذه
القشره الارضيه ليست كتله واحده هذه
القشره الارضيه يعني فيها كسور وبالتالي
اتقسمت الى ما يقرب من 12 قطعه على مستوى
العالم القاره الافريقيه موجوده في قطع
نسميها الشريحه او الصفيحه الافريقيه
القاره الاوروبيه ملتحمه مع اسيا في قاره
في شريحه نسميها الاورو اسيويه هناك
التقاء ما بين الاتنين الالتقاء ده فعل
وبالتالي هناك انزلاقات وهناك زلازل يوميا
هذا الالتقاء عند جزيره قبرص وبالقرب من
الحدود التركيه ناتي الى الجهه الشرقيه
هنلاقي في الخدود الافريقي العظيم ممتد من
البحر الاحمر والبحر الميت ومتصل شمالا
الى الاناضول وبالتالي هناك فال اخر بيقطع
تركيا من الشمال للجنوب هنا تركيا نفسها
ككتله صخريه واقعه ما بين هذه الشرائح هي
منطقه تجمع الفوالق منطقه تجمع الفواصل
وبالتالي بيحصل حواليها انزلاقات من كل
جانب ومن هنا بتاتي تركيا هي المنطقه
الاولى في المنطقه عرضه للزلازل يليها
مباشره ايران ثم بعد كده سوريا وجزيره
قبرص لان جزيره قبرص ايضا عند التقاء
الصفيحه الصفيحه الافريقيه مع الاوروبيه
هذا الواقع الجيولوجي واحنا شفنا زلازل
سنه 99 كان شدته سبعه وسته من عشره وراح
ضحيته 30,000 امارات توفوا في هذا الزلزال
والزلزال اللي هو بزلزال النهارده حصل سنه
39 ولم تشهد تركيا زلزال اشد من سبعه
وثمانيه من عشره زلزال 39 راح ضحيته
التلاته وتلاتين الف واحنا طبعا هذا الرقم
ضخم جدا اذا ما قرن به عدد السكان ايامه
في سنه 39
والكتله دكتور عباس اسمح لي استغله بمعنى
اكثر نعم
ذكرت انه
هذا الكم من الزلازل الكبير جدا خاصه انه
اكثر من 200 زلزال يعني قبل قليل كان هناك
حديث على انه سجلت هزه ارتداديه اخرى كذلك
في الاراضي التركيه دكتور عباس الى متى
يمكن ان تستمر هذه الهزات الارتداديه ما
هو المعدل الطبيعي
لاستمرار الهزات الارتداديه ما بعد الهزه
الاولى القويه
نحن امام مجموعه من الزلازل وليس زلزالا
واحدا يمكن الزلزال الواحد بيبقى له توابع
من نفس المكان لكن نحن الان لدينا اكثر من
230 زلزال في اكثر من خمسين موقع وبالتالي
كل موقع له توابع الخاصه به فاذا الزلازل
شجعت بعدها زلزال الاول اللي حصل منذ
حوالي عشرين ساعه هذا زلزال هو اللي حفز
بجميع الفوالق الموجوده في المنطقه ونشطها
وبالتالي حصلت الزلازل نظرا لشدته القويه
والحقيقه يعني خلال الشهور الماضيه كان
فيه زي بوادر ان في نشاط زلزالي كان زائد
في وخصوصا في شهر نوفمبر نهايه نوفمبر كان
النشاط زائد وكان في زلزال شدته السته
وواحد من عشره لكن اثاره ما كانتش فيها له
اضرار واضحه وبالتالي كان هنا في يعني
بيدي شواهد لكن ليس لدينا وسيله علميه ان
احنا نقول ان في زلزال هيحدث غدا او
الساعه كذا او القادم او الشهر القادم لكن
في شواهد نقول خلينا حذرين ان ربما طالما
اذا لازم زادت ربما الشده ازدادت قليلا عن
المتوسط لان احنا بنرصد يوميا زلازل في
تركيا او في محيط البحر المتوسط نعم لكن
ماذا عن التغريده او التنبؤ الذي احدث ضجه
لاحد
الهولنديين العالم الهولندي الذي تنبا
يعني تنبا تقريبا بشده الزلزال كانت
مقاربه نوعا ما هو تنبا بهذا الزلزال قبل
يومين هل هذه ماحض الصدفه دكتور عباس
علميا لا يمكن التنبؤ بالزلازل هذا علميا
بالزبط هذا علميا توقع صادفه
التحقيق وبالتالي يعني هنا هل توقعه مبني
على اي شيء علمي ما هو الدليل العلمي يعني
ايه الفرق ما بين واحد بيقول انا متوقع ان
هيحصل زلزال قوي احنا لما شفنا نوفمبر
قلنا ان احتمال هيحصل زلزال لكن امتى
هيحصل الزلزال وبعدين هنا يعني احنا لو
اعلنا يومها في 26 نوفمبر لو قلنا ان
هيحصل زلزال هنعمل يعني زعر في الموضوع
لان احنا مش عارفين الزلزال هيحصل امتى هل
خلال اسبوع خلال شهر خلال شهرين وتركيا
دوله كبرى في المساحه طب هيحصل فين في
الشرق ولا في الغرب ولا في المنتصف شمال
جنوب فاذا طالما مش هنقدر نحدد ولا عند
الدليل العلمي يبقى ما يصحش ان انا اقول
هيحصل زلزال وانا ما عنديش دليل علمي لان
ممكن تصادف ويحصل بالفعل بس ده مش معناه
ان انت عندك الدليل اللي تقدر تقدمه
للعلماء والاخرين ان انا
الدلائل الاتيه انا بقول ان في زلزال بكره
هيحصل مثلا الساعه 12:00 عرفت منين وازاي
ما هو الجهاز اللي انت بتقيس بيه وبالتالي
هذا كلام ليس كلام علمي لكن ممكن يكون
مبني على شواهد وتوقعات لكن ليست دقيق
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لكم دكتور
الجيولوجيا في جامعه القاهره
هذا مشاهدينا فقط تحديث سريع لحصيله
القتلى في سوريا جراء الزلزال الحصيله
ترتفع الى 1371 قتيلا في سوريا نقلا عن
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان اظهر مقطع
فيديو في بلده عزمارين في ريف حلب بسوريا
حيث تبدو المنازل وهي قد سويت بالارض
وصارت حطاما بفعل الزلزال القوي نجاح
احنا مرتاحين
وصف الرئيس الفرنسي إيمان والماكرون الصور
المروعه التي تصل من تركيا وسوريا بعد
الزلزال بغير المسبوقه معلنا ان فرنسا على
استعداد لتقديم مساعدات عاجله للسكان
الاتحاد الاوروبي ارسل فرقه انقاذ الى
تركيا مؤكدا استعداده لمساعدتها بعد
الزلزاله المستشار الالماني
عبر عن قلقه اذا اخبار الزلزال في سوريا
وتركيا مؤكدا انهم حتما سيرسلون مساعدات
وزاره الطوارئ الروسيه من جانبها اعلنت
استعدادها لارسال طائرتين الى تركيا
للمساعده في عمليه الانقاذ وابدت واشنطن
قلقها ازاء التقارير عن الزلزال المدمر في
تركيا وسوريا مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي ابلغ تركيا باستعداد واشنطن
للمساعده في جهود الانقاذ بعد الزلزال
فيما اعلن البيت الابيض ان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن وجه بتقييم خيارات
المساعده للمناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال
الرئيس الاوكراني اعلن استعداد بلاده
لمساعده الشعب التركي السويد وعلى لسان
وزير الخارجيتها اكدت استعدادها مساعدتي
تركيا وسوريا بعد الزلزال المدمر الخارجيه
البريطانيه اعلنت استعدادها لتقديم
المساعدات لتركيا بعد الزلزال اما وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه
فاكدت انها تبحث مع الشركاء جمع المساعدات
وارسالها الى تركيا وسوريا
نتابع مع شبكه المراسلين العربيه من
واشنطن نادي البلبيسي من بروكسين نور
الدين الفردي مرحبا بكما معنا ناديه العلي
ابدا معك هل هناك تقييم امريكي لحجم
الاضرار وحجم المساعدات التي تحتاجها
تركيا وسوريا وما الذي ستقدمه واشنطن في
هذا الخصوص
صهيب اولا هناك لقاء هاتفي اتصال بين
الرئيس بايدن والرئيس اردوغان مرتقب خلال
فتره وجيزه جدا البيت الابيض طبعا اعلن عن
دعمه الكامل بتقديم كل المساعدات التي
تحتاجها تركيا وباسرع وقت مستشار او منسق
شؤون الاتصالات في بيت الابيض جونكر بيقال
بان البيت الابيض سيرسل
فريقين كل واحد منهما يتكون من 79
عامل فيه طبعا هذه الفرق هي مختصه في
البحث وفي الانقاذ وستتوجه الى تركيا
باسرع وقت ممكن بطلب من الرئيس بايدن الذي
طبعا عبر عن تقديم العزاء للرئيس اردوغان
والشعب التركي لكن هناك بالفعل حاله
استنفار في الوزارات الامريكيه وزاره
البينتاجون الدفاع وزاره الخارجيه مجلس
الامن القومي جميعها الذين يعتبرون طبعا
تركيا دوله حليفه في حلف شمال الاطلسي
دوله في تقديم كل هذه المساعدات سترسلها
خلال فتره قصيره جدا سواء كانت فرق
الانقاذ وكانت ربما مساعدات طبيه او ربما
محاوله تقديم الادويه للمناطق المنكوبه
للسكان الذين تضرروا هذا في تركيا بالنسبه
لسوريا بالتحديد سؤال وجهته الى جون كاربي
في الاتصال الهاتفي قبل قليل كيف يمكن
الولايات المتحده ان تساعد سوريا وهي التي
تخضع لعقوبات قويه جدا من قبل الكونجرس
ومن قبل الاداره عقوبات مثل عقوبات قيصر
وغيرها عدا عن طبع عدم الاعتراف بنظام
الاسد قال لي بانه سيكون هناك دعم امريكي
على اعلى مستوى لكل المنظمات غير الحكوميه
التي تعمل على الحدود السوريه التركيه
وهناك طلب امريكي طبعا بتسهيل دخول
المساعدات عبر المعابر مع تركيا هذه
المعابر التي كانت انقره احيانا تغلقها
لكن الان وضع الانسان يتطلب تضافر كل
الجهود سواء كانت من هنا او او من هناك
لكن الاداره بالفعل مستعده لتقديم كل
العون وهي لديها خبره خصوصا بالنسبه
لحالات الانقاذ في الكوارث الطبيعيه
وخصوصا الزلازل التي شهدناها في ولايه
كاليفورنيا مثلا وبالتالي ان الاجهزه
الحديثه التي يمكن ان تكشف عن وجود اشخاص
تحت الانقاض يمكن لواشنطن ان تساعد فيها
بشكل كبير وبارسال كل هذه الفرق التي
تحتاجها تركيا هذا عن واشنطن ماذا عن نور
الدين ما الذي ستقدمه اوروبا في هذا
الزلزال
اهلا صهيب يعني طلائعوا فرق الاغاثه والطب
العاجل الاوروبيه وصلت الى تركيا هناك ما
لا يقل يعني حتى قبل ساعات تسعه عشر فريقا
من هذه الفرق
ستقدمها دول الاتحاد الاوروبي يعني تقريبا
اكثر سبعه عشر بلدا اعلنت عن استعدادها
للمساهمه في هذا الجهد الجماعي الذي ينسقه
جهاز الحمايه المدنيه تابعا للاتحاد
الاوروبي طلع هذه الفرق وصلت الى تركيا
ولكن الامر يتعلق هنا بالطلبات التي او
الاستجابه للطلبات التي تقدمها تركيا
تركيا حتى
ظهر اليوم قدمت فقط طلبا للاتحاد الاوروبي
للحصول على فرق النجده وكذلك الطب العاجل
لم تاتي بعد لم نصل بعد الى مرحله السكان
الضحايا الى غير ذلك ولكن هناك مرحليه
هناك منهجيه في عمل الاغاثه وبالتالي
المرحله الاولى تتركزوا بشكل اساسي حول
فرق النجده وفرق الطب العاجل بالنسبه
لتركيا الاتحاد الاوروبي
يفرض انظمه عقوبات على سوريا منذ مده
طويله ولكن التعامل يتم عن طريق هيئات
الاغاثه المحليه العامله او التي تتعاون
مع المتحده او بترخيص من الاداره السوريه
في هذه المرحله بالذات ونحن نشاهد الصور
المفجعه والمؤلمه جدا للسوريين تقريبا
باظافرهم يحاولون ايقاظ الضحايا لا هذه
المنظمات لم تقدم بعد طلباتها الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي ولكن هناك استعداد كبير حسبما
اكد المسؤولون وحتى مساء اليوم مع المتحدث
الرسمي هناك استعداد كبير على الصعيد
السياسي ايضا التقني والخبرات من الجانب
من الجانب جهاز الحمايه المدنيه الاوروبي
للتعاوني معه وتقديم مساعده للمنظمات
الانسانيه
ربما الجانب السياسي او المواقف هكذا
حالات والنظر الى الانسان طبعا
واعود واكد انه كان هناك بعض الشهادات في
خاصه في سوريا مشاهدينا تتحدث عن عدم وصول
اي فرق انقاذ الى مباني مدمره وهناك
محاصرون تحت هذه الانقاض لعل يكون هناك
يعني جهود اضافيه خاصه في هذه المناطق
الحدوديه خاصه في الشمال السوري ساكتفي
بهذا القدر معكم ان نور الدين وناديه اذا
من حتى الان التغطيه ما تزال مستمره
مشاهدينا اعود واذكر باخر حصيله اذا لهذين
الزلزلين المدمرين في المجمل حوالي ثلاثه
الاف قتيل حتى الان في كل من سوريا وتركيا
اثراء زلزالين اذن قويين ضرب اذا بالاساس
جنوب شرق تركيا هذه
تشاهدون الان هي مباشره من ديار بكر في
تركيا حيث تستمر جهود الانقاذ هناك اذا
مشاهدينا تفصيلا للرقم الذي ذكرته 3000
قتيل حتى الان في تركيا وسوريا من بينهم
2316 قتيلا في تركيا واخر حصيله في سوريا
1371 قتيلا حتى الان سته الافئة مبنى تدمر
في تركيا جراء هذا الزلزال الشديد الزلزال
الاول مشاهدينا بلغت قوته
7.8 درجات على سلم ريختر تلاهوا بعد ساعات
قليله زلزال اخر بلغت قوته 7.5 درجه
وطبعا هذا وسط طقس بارد وكما تشاهدون الان
وحلول الظلام كذلك عمليات الانقاذ ما تزال
مستمره